speaking of big collaborative exercises
at d23 we also saw some King well I'm
not sure how much we saw but we saw that
come part 3 is going to be set in Thank
You 6 yeah there's the world san fran
tokyo difference tokyo so cured you
never get that rice do okay I got ya i
feel like a shell for disney though oh
yeah I know San fransokyo don't you know
all about Becky no such a cute GQ movie
um it's uh that was being in that room
was phenomenal they opened the show with
Kingdom Hearts something about kingdom
hearts and Disney Disney for the past
like 10 years in Kingdom Hearts is 10
years old my chest Wow I know is he's
just gonna by square enix now but said
you know what like yeah hmm could work
yeah um Disney Interactive actually gets
the final say for all of Kingdom Hearts
3 which is weird cuz Disney never really
acknowledged like Kingdom Hearts was
kind of like the redheaded stepchild
that they gave away pond birth and sent
it to the to the orphanage or whatever
because they didn't really they're like
oh it's a thing using her properties
we're not really it's not really a thing
we talk about uncomfortable but it kind
of doing know again yeah I had friends
who would visit visited disneyland
disney world to the Past cosplayed his
kingdom hearts characters I got kicked
out of the park because they were like
that's sad he can't see oh my god there
was this weird like Disney's
relationship with kingdom hearts has
always been like yaoi it exists and
we're just not going to talk about it
yeah disney has with kingdom hearts one
hundred and ten percent embraced it and
like now that i think now they're
acknowledging okay kingdom hearts is
super popular it's reinvigorating our
properties and what game can you forget
fight alongside goofy and donald and
like mickey is this like benevolent
Arthurian king of the universe like it's
too good so now that they've embraced it
they announced that the ultimate unlock
for Disney infinity 3.0 weapon so you
can play with keyblade and then there's
that exclusive Mickey costume coming out
oh no it was exclusive to d23 only five
thousand were made I got one I'm so
excited um but then Kingdom Hearts 3
they they didn't show any footage but
just the announcement itself of coming
out on stage and saying kingdom hearts 3
is going to feature a world from big
hero 6
the crowd went nuts and then they showed
a piece of concept art which is I don't
want to spoil big hero 6 so I'm not
going to say anything about it because
as they explained the events of the
world the big hero 6 world in kingdom
hearts are taking place post the film oh
okay which is interesting because most
Kingdom Hearts worlds in previous games
you us Sora or whoever you are playing
as enters the world and the world state
is within the realm of the movie so for
example you enter the Cinderella world
and you are it's an escort mission
together the book to get her to the ball
it's like it's the stuff like that so
it's odd seeing that they're doing a
post movie world state and I wonder if
if that's what Kingdom art is going to
be it's like everything is settled and
now we're sort of picking up the pieces
of everything that is that has fallen
into place if that's if they're really
wrapping that in that way I'm not like
okay well I hope you're only gonna say
the same thing as me but I was like
Enter the Matrix came to mind but I can
imagine if they use this maybe not the
most flattering comparison but if they
use this as like a through-line to a
sequel to big hero 6 what are you
thinking no no I was also going to say
like you mentioned picking up the pieces
of a shattered world which is also what
kingdom hearts is yet with all literally
terrible games like Oh birth by Sleep
256 no no no no birth by sleep was great
in order of best games it's kingdom
hearts 2 birth by sleep literally
everything else with kingdom hearts 3d
at the bottom cuz that game was garbage
do we know what other worlds gonna be
kingdom hearts to you what a dns over
the past like since they talked about
they announced tangled at e3 and
Hercules was revealed through and
through a weapon wash but it's as item
relevance anymore yeah her keys ever
feel is that even relevant a circular
saw well the lion king is like you kids
today is still gonna have Cinderella
they have the mainstays Little Mermaid
Hades is a Hades is a very funny
charismatic villain and I have to
imagine that they keep him around for
doing stuff like that you got a good
characters good stuff the Hercules world
has been in every Kingdom Hearts came to
date you fight and calcium you do
whatever so I'm assuming that that's
gonna be there are tangled I'm hoping I
know that they've said that they're not
going to do frozen but they'd be dumb to
not include frozen would they do Star
Wars so
I've heard things from different people
and because Star Wars and Marvel will
start with a I heard that star was
involved well Marvel are not true Disney
properties so they might not use them
however big hero 6 is a marvel property
I think at this point not including a
Star Wars world would be totally foolish
I just want to see Mickey Mouse come out
the friggin lightsaber the lightsaber
keyblade or whatever it def baby's head
off that's what we all want to see no
good make it happen to see what is
happening over at Disney Interactive
because like between everything they've
done with the toys to life stuff between
like opening up things like kingdom
hearts I think about what happened with
like the Grim Fandango remake we're like
they couldn't do that with Lucas and
then suddenly like it's happening like
suddenly Double Fine have like the
rights that they just allowed them to do
it like there's a big shift happening in
their games department the past couple
years and that shift is how can we make
money oh yeah no it's definitely
definitely revenue driven but it's there
they're embracing all of the like by
taking in Star Wars and taking in Marvel
instead of acknowledging the kingdom
hearts is this big thing I think Disney
is saying hey we're listening to you we
know you want this stuff so we're going
to like give it to you and we're going
to support it their Kingdom Hearts
announcement they had baymax come out on
stage like the door was too small so he
like squished out and he like did the
pound thing with the president of Square
Enix and they're standing on stage and
it's like they're talking about how
they're there they're so excited to be
working with it working on the game and
everything and I think Disney is really
embracing that interactive element like
we've got battlefront and we have the
battle pod which is the thing and Disney
infinity they are pouring so much
resources into did so many researchers
into disney infinity yeah I'm so excited
we've talked a lot about Disney I so
we'll leave it at that thank you so much
elects very courageous thank you
you